what do you make of Harry's visit to the
coronation because he was on the ground
yeah for such a short amount of time
listen this visit was a blink and you
miss it visit I mean he was here for
just over 24 hours he got in late on the
Friday and by the time that the royal
family were having the official pictures
taken here at Buckingham Palace Harry
was already on route to the airport so
it really was a fleeting visit and I
think he'd never looked more like a
spare part you know and that word spare
obviously his autobiography but to me I
looked at him and just thought you look
like a spare part and I think many
people including some members of his own
family wondered why he bothered coming
at all yes he can say that he was at his
father's coronation thank goodness he
was there because it would have looked
terrible had he not been but really
couldn't he have been at that lunch at
the palace there was a place set for him
at the table his father the king would
have welcomed him with open arms and I
think it was a great shame because there
was no interaction between him and any
of the family members that mattered did
he and William make any eye contact at
all I couldn't see any sign of eye
contact whatsoever I mean the Prince of
Wales was in a completely different
position he was part of the royal
procession he was there in the front Pew
he was up there swearing allegiance to
his father Harry was three rows behind
pretty much hidden by his aunt princess
Anne's hat she had a very sort of
pointed hat which was the original blues
and Royals the official uniform of
theirs with a huge feather which meant
that he was largely obscured actually
for most of the servers I couldn't see
any interaction between him and William
and I'm told from very reliable sources
that while they were both in Windsor on
that Friday night and really not far
from each other Frogmore Cottage isn't
far at all from where William and Katie
living at Adelaide Cottage there was no
contact between the brothers there are
several memes that were made of Harry's
facial expressions I know Harry pretty
well and for all of the sort of smiles
and the joshing with Jack Brooks Fang I
think Kevin that inside he was feeling
as crumpled as his deal suit looked from
the back and that was pretty crumbling
people gave him some grief for wearing
Dior didn't they had he been in a Savile
Rose suit would it have creased so much
I'm not sure but he did look a little
untidy from the back and as I say
crumpled and I can only imagine that
inside he was feeling pretty shoddy one
of the interesting things that we saw
that you didn't see on TV was Harry
after the coronation walk out of the
Abbey and he waited out there he talked
for a few minutes with Jack Brooksbank
and other folks and then he stood there
by himself waiting for his car it felt
sad and it looked like he was alone what
do you make of that moment well I think
it was the absolute image of an outsider
of someone who is not a part of his
family who has been cuss adrift and
personally I I think it was very very
sad there was a place set for him at
that table so that he could have been
that informal lunch he was never going
to be part of that balcony lineup he was
never going to be up there because he's
not a working member of the royal family
but he's still a member of the royal
family he's still the King's son and I'm
told from a source very close to Charles
that whatever has happened Charles loves
Harry
and would have loved for him to have
been at least a part of those family
celebrations let's say that Harry does
go to that luncheon he walks in there
Williams in there there's some other
people who have very hard feelings
towards them how awkward would it have
been if he had showed up to that lunch
listen of course it would have been
awkward we know he's not spoken to his
brother they're not on talking terms
there is a fraud work between them that
may never ice over but there is also a
king who loves his son and I think would
have gone out of his way to have made
Harry feel welcome and I think for the
king's big day you just put on a brave
face and you just get on with it and I
think it's a shame that that Harry
didn't do that the fact that there was a
place set at the table showed that there
was an open invitation he didn't take it
that was his choice do you think
Archie's birthday was used as an excuse
I think Archie's birthday was very
convenient for the prince I mean any
parent of course doesn't want to miss
their children's big day but actually
there's only one coronation there's only
one chance to see your father crowned
King he comes back this summer do you
think he will bring his family this time
so that the king can see his children
well Harry is back he's back for for
court cases coming up and he's also
all sevens in Germany this summer so
there's every chance he might come to
the UK but where's he going to stay he
doesn't have the keys to Frogmore
Cottage anymore there's a big
redistribution of the raw houses and we
know that Harry and Megan now that
they're living full time in America have
lost their UK home so if he is here
they're going to have to find somewhere
for him to say I think it might be a
while before we see Harry and his family
here in Britain well Katie they have a
lot of rooms in there they have a lot of
rooms in Clarence well this is still
being refurbished at the moment of
course they can always find a place
there are places there are plenty of
places for them to stay I think it's
really a case of do they want to come
back do they feel that they're going to
be made welcome I think the fact that
Harry didn't turn up at all for that
lunch to actually see his father and
speak to him in person shows that yes
all right we know there have been
conversations but really there is still
a very real rift at the heart of the
House of Windsor
Charlotte noticing her father walking on
stage and her point is like wow there's
my dad yeah I think you you can see
whether it's with them when they're
helping out the scouts or watching them
at the service or watching Charlotte
pointing out so proudly her papa as he
comes onto the stage you see how close
this family is you see how much love
there is between them and I think you
know William and Kate are are brilliant
parents and I think the world's got to
see that and of course this is the
future they are the future of the House
of Windsor do you think they're tighter
because of what happened with Harry
Harry leaving the family that that's
pulled them together even tighters well
tighter smaller circles listen I I think
they were always a really tight-knit
Circle Kate comes from a very close
family and let's not forget actually we
should mention the importance of the
middletons being in the sixth or seventh
row was very very close to the main
action so they've always been a close
family but I certainly think that for
William and Kate they've become closer
than ever because the last two years
have been really really tough for
William he's lost his brother he's lost
his best friend and Kate's been an
incredible support through all of that
[Music]